My hobby is to invent stuff and I do a lot of stuff.
For example, inventing this type of stuff, right here, transformers.
You get what I'm trying to say here, but I made a clock.
That was really easy.
I want to show her something small at first.
But it took a wrong point, and when they saw it was a bomb,...
...so I got arrested for a hoax bomb.
An officer and the principal came and took me up,...
...and they took me to a room filled with five officers, which they interrogated me.
And searched through my stuff and took my tablet and my invention.
And then later that day, I was taken to a Juvenile Center detention center,...
...where they searched me, they took a fingerprint.
No, I never said anything about... I have a bomb, never.
It made me feel like I wasn't human.
It made me feel like a criminal.